hallo
herzlich willkommen in meine torten welt
heute gibt es von mir ein weiteres oster
rezept eine kleine oster idee ich mache
nämlich aus hefeteig kleine ostereier
und osterhasen und wenn ihr wissen wollt
was sie an zutaten benötigt dann bleibt
jetzt an der hefeteig wird jetzt ganz
normal hergestellt sowie auch beim
lostopf also mit 500 gramm mehl 250
milliliter lauwarm amerika einem ein
würfel hefe 80 gramm zucker ein halber
teelöffel salz und 80 g weiche butter
ich mache meinen tag heute im thermomix
aber wir wissen können wir den in jeder
anderen küchenmaschine auch machen oder
eben auch per hand kneten
dazu kommt da jetzt einfach alles rein
die hefe zerdrückte ich ein bisschen
dann die mädels und bevor jetzt das fed
dazu kommt was ich dass etwas verkneten
denn sonst geht er die gräfin ist
richtig auf so beständig jetzt zwei
minuten ein
verschließt ihm den thermomix und stücke
auf das symbol wenn es dann ein bisschen
verrückt ich oder magnetisch kommt dann
noch die butter mit rein und stand lass
dir denn hefeteig ganz durchkneten
wenn ihr dann schönen hefeteig kommt er
einfach raus einfach auch mit bemehlten
arbeitsfläche
machte daraus ein von der kugel
genetische und dann muss der teig
abgedeckt an einem ort etwa eine halbe
stunde gehen die ostereier werden jetzt
noch gefüllt ich auf meinem letzten mal
ein flug ab masse gekauft und habe die
dann als füllung benutzt ihr könnt aber
zum beispiel auch marzipanrohmasse
nehmen oder die nuss bildung verlust
zopf oder jeder andere füllung die ihr
möchtet da ich heute ist keine lukas
masse da aber gern trotzdem nur bayern
möchte mache ich jetzt meinen look hat
einfach selber und wie ich das mache
eigentlich im nächsten schritt für den
selbst gemachten nougat braucht ihr nur
vier zutaten und zwar ist es einmal 50
gramm butter 75 gramm puderzucker 75
gramm haselnüsse die sind ganz und
ungeschält wie ihr sehen könnt und 100
gramm zarter schokolade
zuerst gibt jetzt die harfenistin eine
reihe und lasst sie dabei mittlere stufe
etwas anrösten und in der zwischenzeit
könnt ihr schon mal ein wasser
bereitstellen und da die schokolade drin
schmerzen
bis zu den haselnüssen aufpassen dass
sie nicht verbrennen
deswegen auch nur mittlerer hitze und
sobald die schokolade geschmolzen ist
gebt ihr da noch die butter mit rein und
dann kann die sich auch noch auf loeb
also erst sobald sie etwas farbe
angenommen haben reicht es ahnen können
dass sie vom herd unternehmen und die
riechen dann auch ganz gut dass ihr
merkt eigentlich am geruch wenn sie
soweit sind hier sie dürfen halt nicht
schwarz werden die städte kurz zur seite
zum abkühlen und früher so lang die
butter vallori und die rollen wir jetzt
so lange bis die butter sich aufgelöst
hat ja eine geschmacksprobe muss sein
schmeckt gut schmeckt lecker
nein das reicht okay wenn sich die
butter dann komplett aufgelöst hat ist
es soweit fertig jetzt mache ich mit
haselnüssen weiter und zwar müssen jetzt
haselnüsse und puderzucker gemahlen
werden
ich warte für den termin aber dass
eigentlich jeder andere küchenmaschine
auch ich gibt es da jetzt einfach
zusammen rein und jetzt werde ich das
auf höchster stufe schön fein mahlen
so sieht es danach im ersten durchgang
raus und werde euch das nicht fein genug
ist dann macht ihr denn mixa noch mal an
so dass wirklich alle teile ganz fein
sda nach dem zweiten mal aus schokolade
mit der butter dazu und dann lasse ich
das einfach noch mal durch mixen und das
war's dann auch
das mache ich jetzt auf stufe sieben
oder acht dann habt ihr so eine etwas
dickere maße und sprechstunden das
fertige mutter ich habe hier meinen teil
und da erst richtig schön aufgegangen
ich nehme davon ist die hälfte und zeigt
euch mit der einen hälfte wie ich die
nutzer daher mache und mit der anderen
hält zu zeigen euch dann sehe ich die
häschen machen und mit der hälfte des
tages bekommt ihr etwa zwölf eier und
auch zwölf häschen aus
und den denke ich jetzt noch ab und
stellen noch mal so wie ich meine
arbeitsflächen bisschen und form aus dem
teil zum strand dann halte ich mir den
teig und dieses stück teil jetzt jeweils
in sechs teile hier wiegt jetzt jedes
teilstück etwa 40 gramm und jetzt vorm
ich mir die teigstücke zu kleinen kugeln
im set sie auf etwas mehr als letzte
jetzt nehme ich mir mein selbstgemachtes
lukat wie gesagt ihr könnt auch lukas
kaufen oder eine andere führung machen
wie marzipan oder eine nuss füllung wir
beim lostopf dass ich euch überlassen
ich mache das jetzt aber nur mit diesem
luckert nehme ich mir etwas mehr und ein
teiglinge und drückte ihn etwas
auseinander und dann nehme ich mir mit
dem mit zwei teelöffeln etwas von der
low carb masse und form sie etwas rund
einfach vom einen löffel auf den anderen
zehn
am stand in die mitte und dann lege ich
oben den teig einfach zusammen und
knüpfte in so zusammen also
zusammendrücken
nochmal etwas rund formen und dann soll
neuer form bringen etwas oval wir keine
eier machen wollten das auch einfach und
lassen und so setzt sich das jetzt auch
mit vorbereitetes backblech einfach
drauf
hier habe ich übrigens noch ein rest von
der nugg.ad massa die könnt ihr entweder
einfrieren oder ein paar tage im
kühlschrank lagern oder benutzte einfach
als brotaufstrich sowieso eine muss
nutzt creme könnt ihr also aufheben oder
vernaschen ich denke im kühlschrank hält
ließ sich bestimmt bis zu einer woche
länger würde ich den kühlschrank nicht
lassen und dem gefrierfach vielleicht
ein paar monate
mein letztes eis fertig und so sieht das
dann bei mir aus lass dir jetzt noch mal
15 minuten an einem warmen ort gehen und
dann zeige ich euch noch mal und dann
werden sie gebacken während die
ostereier noch in kurven gehen
verarbeite ich schon mal den restlichen
tag weiter die andere hälfte von uns
heraus wer dich jetzt mit etwas mehl
bestäuben
dann wird es ist ausgerollt so etwa
halten zentimeter ich benutze dann
wieder meine eier ausstechformen weil
sie zu eigentlich habt nehmt einfach ein
trinkglas oder im runden ausstecher oder
macht euch eine schablone und schneidet
drumherum
ich wünsch die form passt perfekt um
dann das hasen gesicht zu machen
entfernen das einfach locker wieder
zusammen so dass man eher zu viel luft
wer daraus arbeitet von außen mache
immer das wollte ich gleich noch mal aus
jetzt zeige ich euch aber erst mal wie
ich daraus die häschen geschichte mache
ich so mal rein
und zwar habe ich jetzt da oben die
spitze des eis und ungefähr das breitere
drews einmal um mit der spitze nach
unten und schneiden nicht ganz bis zur
hälfte hier rein und hab dann so
praktisch die zwei ohren wenn man das so
auseinander zieht also das ganze nochmal
spitze form des spitze ende zeigt nach
unten
da schneidig ein nicht ganz bis zum
wechsel drews wieder um und kam die
ohren noch aus bevor ich die jetzt
bestreichen setze ich sie auch meine
bank
so aus jetzt werden sie mit und milch
bestrichen
ich habe es leider keinen eimer deswegen
bestreicht jetzt einfach nur mit milch
ansonsten einfach ein ei mit etwas milch
etwas verrühren und durch diese
einmischung werden die häschen dann
schön braun und außerdem trockenen sind
nicht aus erfüllt also doppelten zweck
und dann habe ich jetzt einfach ein paar
shopper tropfen die kürzlich ins auge
ihr müsst die deko immer schön rein
drücken dass sie später nicht
einfach eine haselnuss
ihr könnt auch einem angegeben aber die
haselnuss ist so schön rund geformt und
hat unten ja so eine kleine spitze und
ich stecke einfach mit der spitze nach
unten rein und als zähne nehme ich mir
einfach so mandl stifter letztes mal
habe ich einfach mandeln geschält und
halt wird und man die hälfte drauf das
sieht eigentlich besser aus so ähnelt es
nämlich eher vampir zählen als hasen
zählen aber da möchte ich jetzt die
arbeit machen und ihr seht es ja an den
fotos wie die anderen zähne aus und die
häschen gehen jetzt noch mal etwa zehn
minuten und dann werden sie bei 175 bis
90 grad etwa zehn minuten gebacken
einfach so lange bis sie eine schöne
bräune haben
hab ich ganz vergessen die ohren könnt
ihr dann noch mit etwas zimt zucker
bestreuen
das lässt das ganze etwas lecker
schmecken die eier die sie jetzt so aus
jetzt werden sie bei 175 bis 190 grad
etwa 20 minuten gebacken bis sie einfach
eine schöne bräune haben ihr könnt sie
kommen aus den formen falls ihr außer
form geraten sind und wer sie noch schön
goldgelb haben möchte und schreibe
streicht sie dann noch mit einer
beimischung ich habe zwar keinen meter
deswegen mache ich jetzt ohne also wie
ihr wollt entweder mit oder ohne einfach
mal back und danach zeige ich euch wie
es aus meine osterhasen es
fertiggebracht zur sense aus ich habe
sie vor dem backen jetzt doch noch mit
minz bestrichen einfach dass ein
bisschen farbe bekommen und nicht so
bleibt ihr könnt ihr jetzt entweder so
lassen oder ihr besteuerte etwas mit
puderzucker oder ihr könnt mit
zuckerglasur kleine muster drauf
spritzen ich finde sie schmecken so am
besten ihr könnt sie auch zur hälfte in
schokolade tauchen oder was auch immer
also das sind eigentlich eure
kreativität keine grenzen
und so sehen dann die häschen aus wenn
sie aus dem ofen raus sind wenn ihr es
hier mit eigelb und milch bestreicht
angrenzend sie auch noch schön und da
hinten ist der osterhase von meiner
kleinen tochter
und die sind fotos zeige ich euch dann
noch die häschen von meinen schülern aus
der ersten klasse
ich hoffe euch gefallen die eier und
häschen und wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachbarn wünsche euch auch schöne ostern
und schöne ferientage und dann ziehen
wir uns beim nächsten mal bis bald